is Loki going to end up ruling the TVA
being the next king the Conqueror or he
who remains and controlling the
Multiverse in time itself that is
essentially what Loki is asking himself
and the problem that he is dealing with
in episode one that and you know trying
to fix his time slipping and not turn
into spaghetti which he successfully
does but could Loki's glorious purpose
actually be to become the ruler of the
TVA Loki season 2 episode one starts off
with a recap of everything that happened
in season 1 and the recap ends with the
most important part of the finale of
season 1 he who remains telling Loki and
Sylvie that essentially he created the
TVA so the entire Multiverse wouldn't be
destroyed by his variants and he gave
Loki and Sylvie a choice kill him and
then you have an infinite amount of King
the conquerors coming all seeking war
and domination or the two of them could
take over the TVA return as its rulers
and keep essentially the piece now Loki
wanted time to think about this because
he didn't know what the right choice was
because it's not so black and white it's
not so plain and simple however Sylvie
set on Revenge and also partly not
believing he who remains simply kicked
Loki through a Time door and killed he
who remains this results in Loki ending
up back at the TVA however as we
discover he ends up in the TVA back in
time in the past now based off of what
we learned about the TVA before this
shouldn't have been possible the TVA
exists outside of space and time time
and even when Mobius takes Loki to OB
even OB says it's impossible to time
slip in the TVA that is because they
exist outside of space and time it
shouldn't be possible but it is however
at one point in time Loki does mention
that Sylvie uses he who remains Time Pad
to send him back so not just a normal
regular TVA Employee Temp Pad but he who
remains the person who literally
controls time the sacred timeline and
the Multiverse itself his Time Pad which
probably does have the capabilities of
sending somebody through time even at
the TVA of course OB also mentions that
since there are so many Brands timelines
that could also be the reason as well
the TVA is currently being overloaded
the time Loom with all of the new
timelines trying to form it into one
timeline and that could also be the
cause and this is obviously one of the
big issues for Loki in episode 1 now
there is something important to mention
that the beginning or the recap of
episode one of season 2 does not
actually show us in the very last
episode in the finale where Loki is sent
back to the TVA in Loki season 1 we hear
Hunter B15 and Mobi is talking and Mobi
says that's what 63 new branches in this
unit alone and Hunter B15 says does he
want us to just let them all Branch now
this is important because she says he
and she is referring to he who remains
because remember they are in the past
Loki is now in a timeline in a time
period where he who remains controls the
TVA openly as their ruler he has not
invented the guys of the timekeepers yet
he hasn't yet erased everyone's memory
so it's important to note that he is
there somewhere and it looks like Hunter
B15 and Mobius know who he is they know
that he is the leader there are statues
of him everywhere so keep that in mind a
king does exist with his suit because we
can see the statue of him of him wearing
his suit which we learn gives him a lot
of power we learned that from Ant-Man
and the was of quantum Mania a king
exists in that timeline and even though
Loki managed to fix his time slipping we
might visit the past again in future
episodes episode one opens with a shot
of Kang the Conqueror statue and then we
see Loki running away from Mobius Hunter
B15 and TVA agents he gets surrounded he
has no idea what's going on but he tries
to plead to Mobius in which Mobius
replies I don't know you and this of
course is because Loki is in the past we
see the giant TVA City in the background
and if you notice this does kind of look
very similar to the City that Kang built
inside of the quantum realm in Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania which of
course makes sense because the TVA was
created by Kang Loki jumps off the ledge
jumping into a floating truck in which
they then crash into one of the main
rooms that monitors the timeline in
which Loki sees Casey Loki gets out of
the truck and then we see the truck fall
to the ground and it sounds like the
truck crashes but Loki says she'll be
fine and if you notice in the background
the truck does come back into the frame
driving off in the air smoke coming out
of it and another thing you can know
notice is that there are multiple
statues of King the Conqueror in the
background of some of these shots here
so the entire city knows who King the
Conqueror is so again he's around
somewhere in this time now the most
important part of the scene is that the
monitor that's hanging falls to the
ground and it cracks the marble on the
ground Casey doesn't know who Loki is
and then Loki Time Slips again and he
ends up in the same exact spot this is
also another very important detail Loki
when he Time Slips he is just going
through time he is not actually going
through space if you notice every time
that he Time Slips he ends up in the
exact same place whether that's the past
present or future he never physically
moves anywhere so he doesn't go through
space just through time so Loki tries to
plead to Casey because he knew him or I
should say knows him in the future but
since they're in the past Casey doesn't
know who he is so he rats him out but
then he Time Slips again to the exact
same place in the future where he sees
the crack on the floor he sees Casey who
recognizes him now and he asks how long
that crack's been there and Casey says
since as long as he can remember which
tells Loki that he is indeed Going Back
in Forth in time throughout this episode
we see him go to the past to the present
and to the Future as well so Casey is
very confused but he tries to take Loki
to Mobius in which Loki Time Slips again
Casey goes up to Mobius and Hunter B15
and he tells them that Loki was here but
then he just vanished out of thin air
here we learn that miss minut is offline
and that's because we know of course
she's bad she worked for He Who who
remains meanwhile Mobius and Hunter B15
are trying to decide what they're going
to do the timeline is branching out like
crazy but they don't want to prune them
because those are real people with real
lives and Hunter B15 essentially says
that everybody at the TVA should know
the truth and should get to experience
their own lives on the timeline
somewhere but of course Mobius explains
it's not necessarily that easy because
these people believe in the timekeepers
they believe the timekeepers are their
gods who saved them and created them for
the sole purpose of working at the team
VA so to blow their minds by telling
them that they themselves are actually
variants has to really be handled
delicately from here we meet X5 who goes
on to play a very very big role in this
series he asked Mobius about the jet ski
in which Mobius is more than happy to
talk about jet skis however of course we
know that X5 is being condescending and
he informs Mobius and Hunter B15 that
now that Ren Slayer is gone there's a
new judge's Council and they want to see
Mobius in the war room now they leave
and ultimately Loki comes back now this
is one of of the only times Loki appears
in a different room than where he
vanished from but a good explanation for
this could be is that simply in the past
Loki moved he moved to the location that
he appeared back in because most if not
all of the other times he appears
exactly in the same spot where he was in
the future or the past this is just a
one-off time which again can be
explained by him moving locations in the
past Mobius and Hunter B5 get to the war
room where out comes Hunter D90 he sees
Mobius immediately looks to the ground
because he is embarrassed and ashamed
and he tells him I'm sorry I was just
doing my job and that is because he is
the one who pruned him in Loki season 1
episode 4 now at the time he did not
know that the TVA was a sham he did not
know that he was a variant and he had a
life somewhere he didn't know any of
that yet Hunter B15 would go on to show
him that in which she would change his
mind and he would become essentially
kind of a good guy so he says he was
just doing his job what's funny is that
he doesn't actually say that he's sorry
he just kind of keeps looking at the
ground embarrassed and ashamed but
Mobius is a good guy and says you know
what you were following orders it's
actually Ren Slayer that owes me the
apology and here's where it gets really
interesting we see Loki appearing in the
past in the same spot where he was in
the future and he walks into the war
room now nobody is there however it
looks very different than Loki has seen
before and we see statues on the wall of
he who remains then it cuts to the
Future showing us that Loki is indeed in
the past and we see that the statues are
covered up by a mural of the tiny
Keepers showing us that Kang the
Conqueror really did erase everybody's
memories and basically got rid of any
evidence that he created the TVA in
present time Hunter B15 and Mobius go
into the war room where they are playing
a recording of Loki telling everybody
the truth about the TVA telling them
that they were not created by the
timekeepers but were in fact taken from
timelines and are variants of people and
they had lives on the table sits one of
the heads of the Android fake
timekeepers that Loki cut off and the
way that they show this one shot with
the head on the table and in the
background is the mural of the
timekeepers holding the timeline or
timelines as it appears is really meant
to show that everything that they knew
the TVA everything they believed is not
real it's fake the timekeepers are fake
and in the War Room in the present time
we meet two new characters General doc
played by Kate dicki and judge gamble
played by Liz Carr and in the scene you
can tell that both of them are
absolutely terrified of what has
happened it's just been revealed that
everything that they've known their
entire lives is fake and as you can see
General Doc is very well decorated she
seems to have a lot of metals and
ribbons and she's clearly very high up
in the TVA and what's interesting is
that if you look really closely at her
medals some of the faces on the metals
kind of resemble Kang the Conqueror so
I'm wondering if these were medals that
she got working for Kang possibly in the
old war and she doesn't remember because
her memory was erased maybe she thinks
the timekeepers gave them to her or
maybe Ren Slayer and judge gamble is
obviously a judge who has sentenced many
people to be pruned pretty much everyone
and they basically need to decide what
to do moving forward since the timelines
are branching out like crazy and in this
entire scene you can tell that General
Doc is pretty set on still reserving the
sacred timeline despite what she has
learned she states that it changes
nothing their job is to preserve the
main timeline however judge gamble is
much more open and she hears the cries
of Hunter B15 and Mobius stating that
those timelines are actual people and
all they've been doing by preserving the
main timeline is is killing millions or
billions or possibly even trillions of
people so they need to stop pruning and
judge gamble says that her entire life
she's always given off the same verdict
as a judge guilty and had the people
pruned because the timekeeper said so
and you can look at her face and tell
how upset she is and then you see Mobius
and you can tell how upset he is as well
because they have realized that they
have indeed been killing those millions
or billions or trillions of people
that's a lot of people to have on your
conscience and it does seem like the
person in charge here the highest rank
here is Judge gamble because she issues
the order that the TVA will no longer
prune the time branches and that's right
when Loki comes back Loki finally sees
Mobius and he determines that he is in
the present Mobius knows who he is Loki
says he found him and then he looks to
where the statues are but they're not
there they're covered up by the mual so
of course he reveals them and he said
that's who did it that's who created
this place and took your lives and this
makes it pretty much real for judge
Gamble and for General Ducks it's not
just hearsay anymore it's not just the
testimonies of people they are
witnessing it right in front of their
faces however General Ducks asked Loki
where Sylvie was and when they leave she
takes Hunter X5 aside and says the
timekeepers were fake but the warnings
were real and that they're going to find
Sylvie and here kind of starts the
biggest dilemma for Loki and actually
the TVA itself and I have a feeling this
is going to be a pretty big ordeal for
Loki in the entire series and that is
the question of is the TVA actually a
necessary evil was he who remains
technically doing the right thing
however bad it was to save the entire
Multiverse now that he's gone are more
evil variants going to come and start
multiversal war and essentially destroy
the entire Multiverse this is what Loki
is telling Mobius when they exit the War
Room he's essentially telling Mobius
Sylvia wanted to kill him but how could
she be so sure because in the Loki
season 1 finale Loki was trying to stop
Sylvie so they could just take a second
to think to decide on if this is
actually the right move to kill him and
allow more evil variants to come and
destroy the Multiverse and Loki even
tells Mobius we got to the man at the
end of time and he made sense he said he
thought it was about freeing the
timeline but that's only going to bring
more war and more variance and Loki
continues to say there was no Simple
Choice it's not black and white maybe he
was right because that is what's coming
and he points to one of the murals that
shows a bunch of different King the
conquerors at war with each other it's
interesting that he chose to keep that
mural of course it shows the multiversal
war before the timekeepers came so it
doesn't really mean anything to the TVA
since they wouldn't know anything about
who started the wars they just believe
that variant did but it's interesting
that he left it as it was showing his
own variants and not covering them up so
Loki explains everything that happened
and he basically wants to plea his case
again to General Doc and judge gamble
but Mobius says we got to get you to
stay here Loki wants to focus on he who
remains but Mobius makes a joke and says
I need a Loki who remains so Mobius is
going to take him to see OB and it looks
like OB is kind of in a secretive place
because they go in the cafeteria and
then they go through an exit door and it
looks like a door that normal employees
don't typically go through they also
pass a poster in the cafeteria that says
minimize chitchat in the cafeteria
please limit your lunch break to 17
minutes doesn't seem like such a good
life working for the TV and we actually
do get a little confirmation that nobody
really goes through this door and visits
OB because OB stay that Mobius was his
last visitor 400 years ago now when they
first get there you can tell that Mobius
doesn't really know him he doesn't even
remember his name but of course Obi
remembers him especially since he was
the last visitor he got Obi does repairs
and advancements and as he will later go
on to state in the episode he actually
wrote the TVA handbook so he's a pretty
big deal and of course his character is
going to play an insanely huge role in
season 2 now this next scene is insanely
clever writing and I believe could play
a very important part in a future
episode of lowkey season 2 we'll break
it down but first big thank you to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
many of you probably know by now that I
personally use hellofresh a lot because
for me it simply makes sense I have a
pretty busy schedule in my day-to-day
life and hellofresh just makes eating
good meals a lot easier for me with over
40 different recipes that I could choose
from each week hellofresh does all the
shopping and meal planning for you
ingredients arrive at your doorstep
pre-portioned and ready to cook along
with pictur step-by-step recipe cards
they literally make it as easy as it
possibly could be the meals are very
quick to make and they do include some
15minute meals as well it takes the
hassle out of meal time but it also can
save you money hellofresh is cheaper
than grocery shopping and 25% less
expensive than takeout that means less
stress of worrying about what you're
going to eat and you save money so if
interested go to hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping that's how
fresh.com sl50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic for 50% off plus free shipping
now here we have a really awesome scene
where Loki Time Slips but time isn't
going to work in the typical fashion
that the MCU is used to or even that the
TVA is used to because essentially what
we have here is a scene where the past
and the present are kind of happening at
the same time Loki Time Slips back in
time again in the same spot so he winds
up right in front of OB OB in the
present and the past cannot believe his
eyes because time slipping shouldn't be
possible but clearly something is up
Obie says something else must be going
on because he's never seen that before
but right as he says that he recalls
that he has seen that one other time in
the past with Loki who is presently
talking to him so we are experiencing
the past and the present kind of at the
same time here now typically based off
of everything that we've learned in the
MCU about time this is not how time
would typically work in fact according
to how the TVA technically works this in
turn should create a branch timeline not
actually affect the future and this is
what they explained in Avengers endgame
as well the Hulk stated changing the
past does not change the future but that
is exactly what is happening here so I'm
sure they'll give us an explanation for
this at least I hope they do at some
point in time in this series we've
stated a few theories in this video but
if you have any of your own drop them
down in the comments down below and they
do confirm this is happening
simultaneously Bia says wait he's
talking to you in the past right now and
you're just now remembering it and Doby
in the past basically says in order to
prevent time slipping to stop it that
person would need a temporal Aura
extractor Obi in the future says that he
does not have one until he does because
Obie in the past starts to build one for
Loki and Bam all of a sudden Obi has one
in the present because one was built in
his past which is currently Loki's
present as well this is actually very
very clever writing and I commend them
for this scene but this is where it gets
a little complicated for Loki and Mobius
when Obi explains how everything has to
be done Obi says that he has to get to
the pour a loom and pull Loki directly
out of the time stream Obi warns Mobius
that if he takes too long out there the
skin will get peeled from his body and
this obviously and understandably
concerns Mobius but Loki hear some bad
news as well he has to tear himself from
every point in time and space AKA he has
to prune himself because that will then
release him from all the points in time
keeping him from slipping and then
hopefully the extractor pulls him to the
present and if it doesn't he'll get
turned into spaghetti now at this point
OB didn't know about the brand Branch
timelines so they all head to the
temporal Loom which is where they needed
to go anyways Hunter B15 joins them and
Obi basically explains that too many
timelines are going into the temporal
Loom and it's not built to have that
many which is causing the power surges
and could be the reason that Loki is
time slipping so they get to the
temporal Loom and it's guarded by blast
doors and on the floor you can read
danger temporal radiation levels
escalate exponentially Beyond this
threshold likelihood of
spaghettification increases 7,000 per
proceed with caution so we have an
official term of turning into spaghetti
which is spaghettification which is the
threat that Loki is about to face now
what's really interesting about this
blast door is that it really looks like
the X-Men door to enter cerebro it's a
giant x with a circle in the middle it
even has some sort of a glass eye
component to it that seems like it could
be the scanner that scans Professor
Xavier's eye to open the door now we
know the X-Men specifically the original
X-Men that I am referring to Professor
Xavier's X-Men from the 2000 movie we
know they're returning in Deadpool 3 and
we know that the TVA and Mobius himself
are going to be a big part of Deadpool 3
as well so perhaps there is some type of
X-Men connection here or perhaps it's
just a cool little X-Men Easter egg that
they did here the door even opens the
same with the circle remaining intact
and the X splitting in half so if
anything it is an X-Men Easter egg but
maybe it doesn't connect to Deadpool 3
now Obi explains what the time Loom is
he says that it's raw time turned into a
physical timeline this could essentially
be the Multiverse turned into one time
how that could happen we are not really
sure we're unsure of how the time Loom
works but we know that we'll run into
Victor timley eventually and we've seen
from the trailers that he himself was
working on his own time Loom so perhaps
it'll be explained however OB states
that it was not constructed to be able
to pull together so many branches he
specifically says the word branches so
these are branches of time so
essentially it is kind of shrinking down
the Multiverse to one universe so Obi
explains that there are essentially too
many timelines going into the time Loom
and that's causing it to overload and
that's a big issue because it's the
heart of the TVA so if it overloads and
explodes the TVA is done so he says he's
got to close the blast doors so he can
work on expanding it essentially because
the first option was pruning the
timelines however they now know that
that is killing millions of people for
every Branch they prune so the only
option left is to expand the time Loom
however once the blast doors are closed
Loki can't be pulled back in so it's now
or never unfortunately Loki Time Slips
and this time however it's to the Future
Mobius during that present time wrote
skin in dust on one of those computers
obviously losing his skin is kind of
bugging him which it would anybody else
but that specific scene shows us that
Loki did indeed go to the Future which
he himself realizes thanks to mobus
writing skin luckily though when Loki
went to the future he still has the
timer that is sync to the loom and again
this is sort of a past and future moment
happening at the same time because it's
all the present for Loki now Mobius
suits up to go out to the time Loom and
Loki frantically searches for a Time
stick so he can prune himself to top it
all off at the same time Hunter D90
comes in and says that General Doc and
her troops are essentially going after
Sylvie more on that in a bit Loki
searches for a prun stick and Mobius
goes out to the time Loom where he is
essentially getting hit with time Obi
explained that if he doesn't make it
back and the blast door is closed he'll
basically sit there and age at a very
insanely rapid rate his suit will Decay
he will age and a skin will fall off and
he'll die so essentially he is getting
hit with time or raw time as Obi
explained now unfortunately the timer
hits green and Loki is not ready Obi
gives Mobius plenty of warnings but
eventually decides he has to shut it
down he has to close the blast doors he
has to protect the TVA and mobus starts
to head back although it doesn't look
like he's going to make it and even OB
says he's not going to make it and it
really doesn't look like Loki's going to
make it either but fortunately we see
Sylvie coming out of an elevator in
which Loki is then pruned now I didn't
catch this the first time but the second
time watching this I noticed that Loki
gets pruned from behind so it doesn't
look like Sylvie is the one who pruned
him because Loki was looking at Sylvia
as she was coming out of the elevator
plus not to mention she was using both
of her hands to open the elevator but if
you take a look here at the scene it is
very clear that Loki got pruned from
behind so it doesn't seem like it was
Sylvie or if it was perhaps it was a
future or past version of Sylvie whoever
it was Loki and Mobius are really lucky
that person was there to prune Loki
because that shoots him into the present
time and he runs into Mobius sending
them both flying back through the blast
doors making them safe Mobius still has
his skin and Loki is not turned into
spaghetti now Loki was in the future and
saw Sylvie so when he gets back to the
present time which is technically the
past of where he just was he tells
Mobius they need to find Sylvie because
clearly she gets involved again somehow
meanwhile we find out that General dock
has gathered a lot of artillery and
troops and is going somewhere and it
looks like she is going to prepare for
an attack and Hunter B15 even states
that all this is just for Sylvie
implying that no way they don't need all
of that just to get Sylvie something's
going on here and that's the end of the
episode until we get to the post credit
scene Marvel is back with its post
credit scenes for its Disney Plus shows
which we're not complaining about at all
and it shows us what Sylvie is currently
up to now just as Loki season 2 episode
one that we just watched starts off
immediately where they left off in the
season finale of Loki that's what we're
seeing for Sylvie in the post credit
scene this is immediately after she
kills he who remains she then comes to
this timeline for whatever reason and
decides that she wants a McDonald's
great sponsor placement right there
however it does serve some great meaning
it shows us where current Sylvie is as
you can tell from the outfit she's
wearing and the scars and blood on her
this is immediately after her fight with
Loki after everything they went through
with elath and after she killed he who
remains so she gets in and doesn't
really know how to order food because
she's been running from the TVA her
entire life plus not to mention Asgard
doesn't have McDonald's and places
around Asgard and other planets don't
have McDonald's as well so she's not too
familiar with restaurants on Earth but
basically says she doesn't want anything
with a face no rats or anything gross
like that the guy at the stand says well
what do you want to try and Sylvie looks
around and she sees something that she
never got to have people at peace living
their own lives she never got to live
her own life she was running from the
TVA since she was a child and she's
never stopped her entire purpose from
since she was a baby was to take down
the TVA so she says that she wants to
try it all because she believes that
it's all over now she killed the person
who was in charge of the TVA her mission
to her is now done she doesn't know
anything that's happening at the TVA
right now she doesn't know that the
entire Multiverse is at Jeopardy because
she essentially didn't believe he who
remains so when she says I want want to
try at all she is talking about the food
in a sense but she's also talking about
life she wants to try having her own
life out and thanks to the McDonald's
promotions that we've seen we do know
that she will be here at McDonald's at
least for a little bit and that's the
end of Loki season 2 episode 1 what did
you think about this I personally really
loved episode 1 I think it's a fantastic
start to the new season and I'm very
much looking forward to seeing where
this all goes and especially How It Ends
going into to Deadpool 3 and Avengers
Secret Wars but overall the tone feels
just like season 1 it feels just like
what we watched in the finale they
introduce some new characters which I
absolutely love I love OB and the other
characters like General docks and judge
gamble really add to the show they add
to the tone and the seriousness of it
and I'm really looking forward to
exploring more of what this means for
the Multiverse so go ahead and let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like this video And subscribe so you
can stay up to date with all things Loki
we'll be doing a bunch of Theory videos
and of course breaking down each episode
so be sure to hit that notification Bell
you can also find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof